the following trailer only spoiled
season 1 of stranger things the bad man
will get us if we show you season 2
before it's on blu-ray today's episode
is brought to you by t-mobile
America's best unlimited network from
the streaming service that's a game of
Thrones away from ruling all of
television and directing duo's like
Tarantino if he referenced films you've
actually seen comes the show that made
the entire world ask have you finished
ranger things yet
stranger things no I don't want to skip
intro this song is awesome you loved the
80s you loved Steven Spielberg you loved
most of Stephen King now you're all
grown up and the real world is terrible
so escape to a slick pinchable series
you'd watch at double speed if it meant
you could get it into your brain sooner
must revisit childhood escape horrible
present-day
visit the idyllic suburb of Hawkins
Indiana a small town where nobody seems
to pay any mind to the giant
high-security top-secret lab with
hundreds of employees when a middle
schooler goes missing a loser's Club
full of Goonies will fan together to
recreate the cutest version of The
Hangover you've ever seen where one
character disappears where his dog wears
well one character is missing teeth one
character is cool and skeptical and one
character is a dangerous liability to
the rest of the group they see all their
mentally there's something seriously
wrong with her like wrong in the head
we'll may be missing but there's plenty
of other strange things to go around
like Mike's sister trapped in a love
triangle between two haircuts Will's mom
who copes with her son's loss by getting
really into arts and crafts Harbor the
cop on a one-man quest a cold every
guard in town and fan favorite barb the
most talked about character with the
least amount of screen time since Boba
Fett look I get it
she's awkward and she didn't deserve to
die but how about the dude at the
beginning got shot just for helping a
lost child where's the hashtag justice
for Benny huh suit up with 2016's
breakout character slash Halloween
costume 11 she's one part Carrie
one part the kid from boyhood and one
part reminder that angle waffles is part
of a balanced breakfast watch as she
expands her vocabulary outside the
secret lab she was raised in what his
friend spit promised snowball mouth
further discovering the joy of
friendship family and fun new ways to
murder people oh wow
she just straight-up exploded their
brains dingy can we just cut back to her
doing something cute again oh he loved
you 11
please don't get caught up with a group
of Chicago street toughs in a standalone
season 2 episode that while providing a
much-needed arc for your character also
completely derail the show's narrative
momentum I mean just spitballing here
journey to the upside down and alternate
dimension that's just like our own if it
were covered in snot ropes and dandruff
it's a dangerous world that can only be
crossed into by the spooky vagina or
this portal in the woods or these
Christmas lights or this fall or boating
in salt water I don't know
credit their lives the deme Gorgon
a monster who's either an invisible
unkillable lightning-fast predator or at
the story demands it a slow-moving golem
who gets wrecked by a 16 year old with a
baseball bat I hope they don't do what
aliens did and replace the big monster
with a bunch of smaller easier to kill
versions again just spitballin so hop on
the back pegs and ride along with one of
Netflix's biggest hits that could have
posted by on pure nostalgia but goes the
extra mile by adding a tight story with
a great young cast who better crank out
the next season's fast cuz if you think
the deme Corgan is relentless wait until
puberty is on your tail clock's ticking
Dustin story
nerds bikes hugs Slenderman
more nosebleeds than a horned up anime
character
Wynonna face
[Music]
but this award from you who take your
craft seriously and earnestly believe
like me that great acting can change the
world will
mucks idiot dead loki stealing the show
i hope you're enjoying your chicken Ted
what did I do
what Dino waffles aren't your breakfast
being able to talk to Mike's mom I want
you to feel like you can talk to me
Nancy
what you can talk to me Joyce if you
need anything
Ted and I are here for you conflicted
Nancy face
blinking lights right 11 books
I understood that reference like
Professor X is from Lord of the Rings
boy Yoda like Michael Myers aren't you
going to fight Darth Vader these shots
from et jaws Halloween et again a
Nightmare on Elm Street stand by me an
American Werewolf in London and et you
can use the force to move things with
his mind and the only way pop culture
knows how to explain alternate
dimensions you create a doorway the
spacecraft passes through the gateway so
you can take a shortcut through a higher
dimension nostalgic things you know
what's gonna suck when TV shows get
nostalgic for 2017 and show kids dabbing
on a hoverboard like it wasn't the worst
time ever today's episode is brought to
you by t-mobile switch to America's best
unlimited Network leggo my eggo
another day another dud tomatoes are
just weird apples your hair is winter
fire January embers my heart burns there
too